[Music]
one important and particularly
interesting relationship in ursula k le
guin's sixth earth sea novel the other
wind
is that between tenar and lebanon
lebanon by this time is a king who has
been reigning for 15 years so he's still
a fairly young king but he's he's had a
lot of experience
and there's some expectations on him
that we're going to see enter into this
relationship tenner has met him 15 years
ago when his boat or ship rather was
sailing near gantt and in the harbor she
and theroux now to hanu were trying to
escape the the man one of the people who
had abused pharaoh and the king takes
them up on board and welcomes her
as both
somebody who is connected with the
former arc mage ged or sparrowhawk who
lebanon had recently come back from this
long quest detailed in the third novel
uh with and who has been avoiding
lebanon and uh tenner and him get to
talk quite a bit
on the
ship as they're sailing towards another
one of the harbors and they get to know
each other and there's a ease and
familiarity and friendship that arises
between them
what we find in the story is is how
leguin uh says that lebanon had spent
only a brief time with tenar though
they'd written a few letters over the
years and this is him seeing her again
now after 15 years he was not yet used
to her hair being gray and she seemed
smaller than he remembered her but with
her he felt immediately as he had felt
as he had 15 years earlier that he could
say anything and she would understand
it's really interesting because this
harkens back all the way to the first
earth c novel where ged
and vetch have that kind of ease of
friendship that time does not
alter they're able to pick it up
immediately from where they've left off
and so this is going to be quite
important they are there
in hovnor
in the the you know the very heart of
earthsea because
theroux or now to hanu and tenor are
going to be consulted by the king about
some issues that have to deal with
dragons but there's some other problems
arising at the same time
the most important of which is this
cargish princess who has been brought
and is being essentially
given in in a
you know an attempt to make a bargain uh
by the high king of the kargish lands
her father to lebanon who is you know
very unhappy about what is going on and
so they're coming to to have nor
originally about one problem they're
going to help him deal with a second
problem
more tenar than than tahanu tahanu's
really dragon preoccupied and as a
matter of fact tenor has to
help out
her daughter her adopted daughter
to hanu to deal with her own emotions
and things like that and to grow into
her uh stature and
what we see is that tenor is going to
give counsel and actually help lebron
and out considerably
with the kargish princess not least
because she is herself you know
originally a kargish priestess and so
she can relate to a certain degree
to what's going on with this unfortunate
as we find out princess who's been used
basically as a bargaining chip and who's
lived a very very sheltered life but who
turns out to be quite a interesting and
good person
we also find out that tenar
functions as a sort of surrogate mother
to
lebanon there's a very interesting
passage here
lying gazing at the stars he turned his
mind deliberately
from those memories and from the thought
of ged who he misses and doesn't
understand why ged won't come to see him
he thought of tenar the sound of her
voice the touch of her hand
courtships were ceremonious cautious
about how and when they touched the king
she was not
she laid her hand on his laughing she
was bolder with him than his mother had
been rose princess of the house of
enlard had died of a fever two years ago
while he was on shipboard coming to make
a royal visit to berlia on unlad and the
isle south of it he had not known of her
death till he came home to a city and
house in mourning his mother was there
now in the dark country the dry country
if he came there and passed her in the
street she would not look at him she
would not speak to him he clenched his
hands he rearranged the cushions of his
bed tried to make himself easy tried to
set his mind away from there to think of
things that would keep him from going
back there to think of his mother living
her voice her dark eyes and her dark
arch brows her delicate hands
or
to think of tennar
he knew he had asked tenor to come to
havnor not only to take counsel from her
but because she was the mother that
remained to him a very important phrase
she is the mother that remained to him
he wanted that love to give it and be
given it the ruthless love that makes no
allowances no conditions
tenar's eyes were gray not dark but she
looked right through him with a piercing
tenderness undeceived by anything he
said or did
he knew he did well
what he had been called to do he knew he
was good at playing king but only with
his mother and with tenor had he ever
known beyond any self-doubt
what it was to be king
not all mothers are like that of course
right and uh
not everybody experiences true motherly
love or anything like that and what we
find interestingly motherly love and
leguin writes this of course as a mother
is not this you know absolutely devoted
self-giving thing oh i'm nothing you're
everything sort of nonsense it is
demanding it asks the best
and provides support to
the person that it's asking the best of
and if you're the king well you have to
be the best king and that is what
lebanon is being called to there's
there's a couple other passages later on
where we see some of this
ceremoniousness but also tenderness for
example when they're getting on the boat
together
lebanon
is going to welcome her
tenar says she
here we go she thought of the day long
ago she and ged came sailing into hobnor
bringing home the rune of peace
alpharon's ring that ring had been on
her arm and she'd held it up so the
silver would flash in the sunlight and
the people could see it and they had
cheered and held out their arms to her
as if they all wanted to embrace her it
made her smile to think of that she was
smiling as she went up the gangplank and
bowed to lebanon he greeted her with the
traditional formality of a ship's master
mistress tenor be welcome aboard
she replied moved by she knew not what
impulse i thank you son of alpharon he
looked at her for a moment startled by
that name
so
they can engage in the ceremony but we
also find out a little bit later right
they're talking about ged's questions to
tahanu
and
she says i don't i don't know what the
answers are only what the princess told
me i'll speak with tahani about these
things tonight he frowned pondering then
his face cleared he stooped and kissed
tener's cheek bidding her good night he
strode off and she watched him go
here's a great description she mel he
melted her heart
he dazzled her but she was not blinded
he's still afraid of the princess she
thought so she can see into him she
knows him with a sense of intimacy that
a mother a good mother would have a good
parent would have to be able to know
what's actually going on
with your children she's also upset with
him
at a certain point particularly early on
when he's explaining what is going on
with the the princess and we see
some interesting uh remarks here
lebanon had left the audience scowling
again what was wrong with him
so far she knew
he had never before rebelled against the
obligations of his position
certainly he knew a king must marry and
has little real choice to whom
he marries
he knew that a king who does not obey
his people as a tyrant he knew his
people wanted a queen wanted heirs to
the throne but he'd done nothing about
it
women of the court had been happy to
gossip to tenor about his several
mistresses none of whom had lost
anything by being known as the king's
lover he'd certainly managed all that
quite well but he couldn't expect to do
that forever
why was he so enraged by king those
offering him a perfectly
appropriate solution mary mary my
daughter and our two kingdoms the two
main kingdoms and earth see will be at
peace forevermore we can bind ourselves
together these two ethnicities these two
peoples that have been at war for
you know hundreds perhaps thousands of
years
and tenner thinks to herself
imperfectly appropriate perhaps the
princess was something of a
problem
and before we come to the solution we
should read on
she resented lebanon's failure or
inability to take the girl's point of
view she not only is upset about his
rebellion not not you know getting
married as he should in his anger
but also his lack of sympathy an
uncharacteristic
lack of sympathy
she says couldn't he imagine what it was
like for her brought up in the women's
quarters of a warlord's fortress in a
remote desert land where she'd probably
never seen any man but her father and
uncles and some priests suddenly carried
off from that changeless poverty and
rigidity of life by strangers on a long
and frightening sea voyage abandoned
among people whom she knew of only as
irreligious and bloodthirsty monsters
who dwelt on the far edge of the world
and not truly human at all because they
were wizards who could turn into animals
and birds and she was to marry
one of them when you frame it like that
if lebanon could see things that way and
not just from his own perspective
then perhaps
you know he could have much more
sympathy
for this this princess
um
and you know we see that this this is
going to be an issue
she doesn't understand why lebanon can't
exert himself this way but she's going
to help come up with a
solution
and
that comes back to the you know helping
lebanon out with the carcass princess
she is going to
teach her she's going to ensure that she
does in fact not just learn
the heartic tongue of the archipelago in
in place of her native carcass
but that she comes literally out of the
shell of her
veil and gets to know this person
lebanon as a matter of fact
tenner takes kind of baby steps with
this there's there's a point where the
princess gives her her name and then
says don't give it to the king because
he'll use it to try to ensorcel me
that's what these people do and tenor's
like listen kid that's not how things
work here but when tenner is talking to
the king lebron and she says i can't
give her give you her name yet because
she doesn't want you to have it at this
point in time and so tenor works as a
very important go-between
and a you know very much like a motherly
figure and a future mother-in-law
to this kargish princess who is going to
be marrying lebanon and the two of them
will in fact fall in love
by the end
but it's going to be largely
due to all the efforts that that tenor
is pointing in to smooth away to figure
out what the obstacles are and you know
this is this is going to be an
incredibly
important relationship going on and it's
kind of a
a tender picture that we get to see
tender and like 10 are also
quite tough
so
a really important supportive
relationship that allows us to see these
two characters developing in relation to
each other and in relation to their
duties and their relationships with
other characters
you